[Aplausos]
la ansiedad
es un problema que mucha gente tiene
pero pocos comprenden así que déjenme
explicarles qué es la ansiedad
y estoy seguro que todos ustedes aquí se
han sentido ansiosos alguna vez en su
vida cuando le van a hablar a una chica
guapa a un chico guapo cuando tienen una
presentación importante o una entrevista
importante ahí se pisan acalorada no y
empieza su cuerpo se empieza es
controlar yo que sé
yo no hablo de este tipo de ansiedad
yo hablo del tipo de ansiedad que puede
prevenir acciones de tu día a día como
ver una película o ir al gimnasio
este tipo de ansiedad tengo yo
y como a todos los que tienen ansiedad
se manifiesta por una razón o por un
miedo específico mío
mi miedo específico es la falta de
control de mí mismo
entonces les voy a explicar lo que me
pasó hace algún tiempo
un día me enfoqué en mi boca y sentí que
mi boca se méxico y sentía que esa
resequedad era mi culpa y que no podía
hacer nada para controlar eso luego vino
a mi voz
lo mismo me pasó con mi voz
me enfoqué en mi voz y cada vez que
conversaba con alguien sentía que no
podía controlar las palabras que decía
ni la manera en la que negocio nava y
eso me daba miedo es rarísimo pero pero
me daba miedo y me sentía ansioso y me
quedaba tan desgastado que llegaba a la
casa y no tenía más energía que para
dormir
estas dos cosas pude superar se puede
decir de una manera sencilla ya que lo
de mi boca puede marcar como ridículo ya
que dije estamos en una época de falta
de humedad frank para de ponerte loco y
luego en mi voz decidí aceptarla y
quererla tal como es sin embargo luego
vinieron mis ojos y con mis ojos fue una
situación mucho más complicada ya que
tú no puedes aceptar tus ojos no suenan
no les voy a dar un ejemplo cuando
estaba con una persona conversando
hacia el contacto visual y sentía que
todo lo que estaba haciendo estaba mal y
sentía que le estaba volviendo incómoda
esa persona y sentía que estaba teniendo
mis ojos abiertos más tiempo de lo
normal y eso no solo me pasaba cuando
estaba solo
también me pasaba cuando estaba pero no
solo me pasaba cuando estaba con gente
también pasaba cuando estaba solo viendo
una película o mirando por la ventana se
volvió una pesadilla ya no podía parar
de ver es la cosa más loca pero paso
en el transcurso del tiempo en el que
tuve ansiedad pude
por mis propios medios encontrar
bastantes maneras de que baje su
intensidad de poder controlarla déjenme
compartir esto con ustedes
la primera técnica que encontré o
terapia es la terapia cognitiva
conductual
de qué se trata la terapia
cognitiva-conductual la terapia
cognitiva-conductual se trata de
enseñarte de ver las cosas de una manera
diferente lo que cree esta terapia es
que la conducta se aprende y cómo se
puede aprender también se puede
cambiar por otro aprendizaje entonces en
vez de comport antes de comportarte de
cierta manera por una situación te
enseñan a comportarte de una manera
diferente
la segunda cosa que les quiero compartir
y que esto no solo ayuda para todas las
personas con ansiedad ayuda a todos aquí
hay millones de charlas ted que hablan
de esto
es controlar el lenguaje corporal
si es que controlan su lenguaje corporal
puede cambiar su vida
hay que darles un ejemplo como están
nerviosos y su cuerpo se empieza a
descontrolar o no
les digo a los prueben esto cuando
salgan y miren cómo cambia su humor cómo
cambia lo que sienten
cuando estén nerviosos póngase en una
posición relajada y ahorita estoy
nervioso me voy a poner en una posición
relajada listo
todo lo que sientes cambia te relajas es
como si estás mintiendo a tu cerebro
la tercera cosa que quiero compartir con
ustedes y que me parece lo más
importante es dejarse sentir
varios estudios incluyendo estudios de
la universidad berklee y de la
universidad
de la universidad de toronto han
demostrado que si una persona se deja
sentir lo que es correcto para esa
persona vive una vida más sana y más
larga
entonces sientan cuando tienen que
sentirse triste siéntanse tristes cuando
tengan que sentirse ansiosos denle una
bienvenida y sientan sancio sus pero no
se obliguen a sentirse felices porque la
sociedad impone que sentirse feliz todo
el tiempo es correcto
estas son las tres cosas que les quiero
compartir pero lo que quiero recalcar de
todo esto es que yo les puedo dar tips
yo les puede enseñar ciertas cosas que
pueden utilizar todos en su vida no solo
la gente que tiene ansiedad sin embargo
el cambio está en nosotros mismos
ustedes deciden si es que van a
investigar más si quieren cambiar su
vida si quieren que crecer como personas
déjenme decirles algo todas las personas
de aquí que están con ansiedad porque
probablemente hay bastantes personas que
están con ansiedad ecuador es del
onceavo país con mayor tasa de ansiedad
y depresión en latinoamérica y eso sin
contar eso es sin contar todas las
personas que no saben que tienen
ansiedad y todas las personas que no se
atreven a decir en un estudio científico
así que fijense a su alrededor
probablemente hay una persona con
ansiedad en su círculo en su círculo
familiar probablemente hay una persona
con ansiedad en su círculo social
fíjense en esa persona que está así todo
el tiempo que no habla que se queda
callada en una conversación y del afecto
en el amor
y a todas las personas que tienen
ansiedad aquí
a qué les voy a decir es que es muy
difícil tener ansiedad yo lo he vivido
es extremadamente complicado y es
solo tengan en cuenta que la ansiedad te
puede dar desde dolores de cabeza hasta
gastritis
es extremadamente complicado pero hay
maneras en que puedes aprender a
controlarla está en ti está en cada uno
de ustedes
si es que van a hacer ese cambio no
investiguen tienen probablemente la
mayoría de personas de aquí tienen todos
los medios para aprender sobre la
ansiedad y para aprender cuál es su
causa y qué se puede hacer para que baje
su intensidad pero el cambio está en
cada uno cada uno
tiene el poder de cambiar para un futuro
mejor la ansiedad está creciendo cada
día cada día en los adolescentes y el
porcentaje de ansiedad en los adultos es
sorprendentemente mucho mayor que en los
adolescentes así que fíjense en eso y
den amor
el cambio está en cada uno de ustedes
así que cuando salgan de esta charla yo
les pregunto qué es lo que van a hacer
se van a quedar estancados así como
estamos quejándose de que no pueden
controlar su ansiedad de que no no hay
cómo solucionar los problemas de la
sociedad no van a hacer algo
qué van a hacer
muchas gracias